christy dickinson is immunocompromised
and soon she'll have to navigate how to
stay healthy in a world without coven 19
restrictions i would hope that as we
look at reopening
um
that we can do so you know in a in a
thoughtful
you know step-by-step way in ontario
where dickinson lives the province is
moving forward with a phased reopening
plan making it easier for her to adjust
quebec and prince edward island have
also laid out strategies to lift public
health measures over the course of the
next month or so but saskatchewan and
alberta are ripping the restrictions
band-aid right off i think it's a
political decision but
you know science-based decisions you
know often through the pandemic have not
sort of looked at the economic issues so
you kind of have to balance the two but
decision makers have to strike that
balance this epidemiologist says with
local evidence in mind hospital rates
icu rates wastewater rates if they're
going down and they have been for the
last three weeks then we can look
forward to to taking a few more steps
prairie hospitalizations have shown a
slight decline but have not consistently
dipped if we remove mass mandates if we
remove vaccine passports if we remove
gathering limits there's no reason to
think that numbers won't just go up one
of the first countries to choose to live
with covid denmark is now experiencing a
record number of hospitalizations and
although icu numbers remain low covades
remain about the same as they did last
year the spike wasn't unexpected but
canada's healthcare system is more
fragile let's try and keep the increase
to a speed bump
level
not another cliff face of an increase we
want to control it dickinson worries
another wave means she won't be able to
access in-person care
that's a really
important
aspect of the reopening for me and for
so many others who have had their health
sidelined because of the pandemic jamie
morocco global news toronto